[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 invités voici les titres
nous irons à la rencontre de l'illinois
tristan couedel il participera à la 9e
édition du paris dakar qui se déroule en
amérique latine nom débute ce 7,8
invité avec les créatrices d'al barra
une société qui commercialise des savons
d'alep en syrie qui sont faits à alep
une belle initiative qui résonne vu
l'actualité de la ville en ce moment qui
est bombardée par l'armée russe et
syrienne bonsoir à toutes les deux alors
on va commencer par vous et n'a je me
permette
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'actualité
en ce moment en syrie alors
malheureusement la guerre continue
toujours en série et notamment à alep
on est trop triste de ce qui se passe à
notre ville qu'elle est détruite et il
ya beaucoup des combats dû sang partout
mais on est un peu choqué par la
manipulation un petit peu de la
désinformation des médias en fait parce
que non syrien allait pain on est quand
même avec l'arrêt de cette guerre
alors pour l'instant ce qui se passe sur
le terrain on est plutôt un petit peu
avec cet arrêt de saint pierre alors on
est un peu petit plutôt optimiste que la
guerre fait terminer bientôt d'accord et
vous avez j'imagine encore de la famille
alors j'ai pas mal de la famille j'ai
mes parents mon frère mes cousins
ils sont pas tous partir parce qu'en
fait tu allais pour nous ça tient
beaucoup à notre ville et moi j'ai
quitté parce que j'ai deux garçons
nous voilà alors pour pour voilà pour
protéger mes garçons alors j'étais
obligé de quitter à lèvres parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de bon d'accord ok hélas
pour le moment les retours c'est un peu
plaisir là c'est un peu compliqué de
retourner oui parce que la guerre et n'a
pas encore terminé on a toujours peur de
rentrer on a toujours peur de la guerre
et malheureusement je ne peux pas dire
que j'ai la chance mais j'étais sorti
avant que je vois mon pays où ma ville
détruit et j'ai beaucoup du mal à
rentrer et de retrouver ma ville
complètement mais vous avez quand même
décidé ici de créer votre commerce
al-bara avec madame alors très content
et moi un petit peu cette marque alors à
sarah alors alvara d'abord qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que c'est beau c'est d'abord
une histoire d'amitié parce qu'on se
connaît on est arrivé en france il ya
maintenant presque cinq ans on était
voisine
on s'est rencontrés par par nos garçons
qui avaient une image et qui était dans
la même école donc
donc on est devenu amis comme ça et
ensuite ses nerfs m'a demandé de l'aider
il ya trois ans ça commence il ya trois
ans même si nos produits sont
commercialisés maintenant que depuis
deux ans le projet est né dans notre
tête est dans notre coeur il ya trois
ans elle m'a demandé de l'aider parce
qu'elle avait à coeur de d'importer ce
symbole pour elle
d'alep d'avoir un petit peu de son pays
avec elle en france sachant que moi je
travaille par ailleurs
donc c'est un projet qui a vu le jour
petit à petit lentement mais sûrement
et c'était aussi une manière pour nous
de concrétiser cette amitié d'accord
voilà
mais c'est pas compliqué de faire c'est
savon alep en tout cas où avant ça reste
c'était compliqué ça reste compliqué en
fait on s'appuie sur des petits
producteurs locaux
il ya deux choses à la partie savonnerie
qui aidons à l'aip et dans ses faubourgs
il faut savoir que effectivement la
guerre a détruit 70 % des savonneries
d'alep mais que comme bénin et syrienne
n'est que son grand-père était maître
savonnier elle avait tout ce réseau
familial qui pouvait permettre qu'ils
pouvaient nous permettre d'importer ces
savants et puis même si la guerre a
détruit un certain nombre de savonnerie
les maître savonnier très courageusement
ont recommencé à reconstruire un peu
plus loin donc il aura fallu peut-être
18 mois pour que à nouveau et puis nous
livrer des savons mais on a réussi comme
ça à maintenir une une production et du
coup à pouvoir importer on a aussi un
petit atelier
voilà on a là deux productions des
cerveaux et puis on a un atelier où on
fait également tout packaging décemment
parce que l'objectif c'est de faire
essayer de faire travailler ceux qui
n'ont pas eu la chance de pouvoir partir
avec ma question
voilà le coach donc il ya 18 ans fait on
arrive à faire vivre enfin on contribue
à faire vivre 18 familles sur place
parce qu'au-delà de la production des
savons il ya aussi donc le packaging
donc là l'impression des boîtes la mise
sous pli la mise sous film plastique
la production des bouteilles donc on a
des produits qui sont assez simples donc
on a une designer en france qui a
travaillé sur le design
mais sur place est imprimé sur place et
demi sous pli sur place dans cet atelier
qui est dans la région d'alep qui n'est
pas à l'être même mais dans la région
alors quelles sont les caractéristiques
le type 2 heures on peut retrouver
venons le savon d'alep c'est en fait
l'honneur de sa bande à l'aide c'est
l'odeur de mon enfance
parce que alain pellet connu par ses
savons et quand on est en fait on est
venu là est en fait l'idée du savon
d'alep c'est un peu de transmettre ce
savoir faire faire de la lettre de ma
ville et garder ce lien un petit peu
avec la syrie est alors le savon pour
moi c'est
c'est l'odeur de l'huile et de lauriers
en fait parce que le savon d'alep
il est fabriqué par deux huiles d'olive
et l'huile de lauriers dès qu'il ya plus
de lauriers dans le savon d'alep des qui
est mieux pour la peau pour tout ce qui
est eczéma en peaux sensibles et en fait
c'est l'odeur un peu particulier c'est
l'odeur d'alep tous avant l'acte et on
peut le retrouver
ou ce savon alors à différents
distributeurs au fret on a une on a une
quarantaine de clients mais on a surtout
une dizaine de gros distributeurs dont
certains dans la région donc notamment
naturéo on a également nature et
découvertes qui est un client en offrant
un troisième voilà on a également bhv
c'est l'un des enjeux c'est fini non
mais par rapport aux barques cfi d ok
très bien à moi en tout cas c'est belle
amitié
j'espère qu'elle va continuer et c'est
de très beaux produits et c'est une
belle entreprise
voilà merci on passe maintenant un tout
autre sujet l'yvelinois attristant quad
elle va tenter de dompter les dunes à
l'occasion du dakar 2010 est pour sa
neuvième année le parcours traversera la
bolivie et l'argentine à partir du 2
janvier
mika l'ennemi droit rencontrer ce
passionné d'automobile dans son garage
nous sommes à mézy sur seine dans les
yvelines je suis avec tristan couëdel
qui va participer au dakar pour la
troisième fois cette année
le compte à rebours est lancé tristan
codel on va peut-être un petit peu plus
vous connaître dans cette interview est
ce que vous pouvez vous vous présenter
alors je me prénomme tristan
effectivement j'ai la chance de la faute
de pouvoir assouvir ma passion de
l'automobile et notamment dans la
compétition du dakar j'ai l'opportunité
de faire du rallye du circuit mais le
rallye raid occupe une place
particulière dans mon coeur puisque les
grandes étendues le désert et toujours
pour moi étaient des choses de très
attractif donc j'ai la chance
effectivement cette année de repartir
sur le dakar pourquoi repartir parce que
il y a deux ans même équipage même
automobile
même pays puisque finalement nous étions
partis au sud de buenos aires et
effectivement on va se relancer dans
l'aventuré cette année
est ce que vous avez appris peut-être
des erreurs du passé je crois que
c'était pas très bien passé la dernière
fois alors en fait ça s'était bien passé
dans l'entente sur le team en revanche
mécaniquement notre auto avec décidé de
jouer des tours donc effectivement on
est entre guillemets récompense tous les
deux pas rester suffisamment longtemps
dans l'aventuré puisque on avait eu un
abandon assez tôt dans la course
et effectivement on a appris beaucoup de
choses à la fois sur la gestion de
l'épreuve mais aussi sur les
aménagements qui était nécessaire de
faire sur notre tristesse qu'il recette
miracle pour finir le dakar ou leur
portée même alors c'est tout l'enjeu
dans le cadre d'un amateur
comme nous sommes l'objectif est pas
forcément d'avoir une place au
classement
véritable en nous ce qu'on cherche à
faire et on a une approche un peu
particulière avec mon coéquipier c'est
qu'on souhaite finir le dakar est prouvé
qu'en 2017
il est possible de finir un dakar sans
avoir de mes cadeaux puisque notre
équipage a la particularité d'être sans
assistance c'est à dire que le soir
quand on arrive au bivouac qu'il soit 22
heures ou 4 heures du matin il faut
reconditionnés nous mêmes notre
automobile de manière à pouvoir partir
d'un moment vous n'avez pas
on va dire les avantages des leaders
alors c'est certain que un leader
d'abord il part plus tôt
il roule plus vite parce qu'il est admis
tomic luca en fr et puis il ya des
compétences qui lui permettent de faire
un résultat il arrive plutôt il part
directement prendre ça vous va dîner et
il reste une part plus tard on arrive
beaucoup plus tard et en revanche il
nous reste beaucoup de travail effectué
donc ces deux courses qui sont dans la
même course donc on peut côtoyer les
professionnels mais pour autant la
proche de la course est totalement
différente notre objectif c'est vraiment
de retourner à buenos aires à l'issue de
la course on va revenir sur sur cette
épreuve du dakar qui je rappelle aux
téléspectateurs se passera en amérique
du sud
encore une fois vous comment vous
percevez cette course elle est
différente peut-être de celle qui se
déroule en afrique
alors disons qu'ils avaient connu les
deux oui tout à fait je l'avais la
chance de faire en 98 en afrique
il ya plusieurs éléments qui changent
d'abord la professionnalisation de cette
course c'est à dire que de plus en plus
vous avez des équipes très structurées
et de moins en moins d'amateurs plus
réduire
on est un peu les derniers des mohicans
à le faire vraiment véritablement en
amateur ça c'est la première partie
ensuite dans le pays
on trouve des paysages aussi bien
magnifique en mauritanie qu'au chili
on va cette année avoir l'opportunité de
découvrir encore plus sur la bolivie
après ce qui va changer il ya deux
facteurs la température on a des
températures parfois on engendre signe
qu'ils sont très élevés et qu'on avait
peut-être un petit peu moins en afrique
et surtout un critère déterminant qui
est l'altitude puisqu'on va passer
pratiquement sept jours au delà de 3500
mètres d'altitude ce qui est un peu
particulier dans des conditions un peu
spécifique qui change de nuit et des
paysages après c'est vrai qu'on trouve
du sable étonnamment en amérique du sud
ça peu de gens le savent puisque
effectivement on est on s'attend à avoir
des dunes en mauritanie un peu moins au
mieux de la bolivie est donc c'est tout
l'enjeu c'est aussi de faire découvrir à
des personnes qui ont peu l'opportunité
de voyager et bien le chili l'argentine
la bolivie c'est un max aussi
intéressant de ce paris dakar on en bave
peut-être un petit peu plus l'amérique
du sud alors je dirais que le je pense
que l'effort physique
l'intensité reste la même c'est à dire
qu'au bout de trois jours vous avez
l'impression que ça fait 15 jours que
vous êtes parti tellement les journées
sont intenses pour un amateur vous
passer entre 12 et 14 heures dans les
spéciales si tout va bien ça peut être
beaucoup plus long la spéciale nous
avons abandonné il ya deux ans on a
pointé 26 heures 30 après avoir commencé
notre épreuve spéciale
et malheureusement on été mis hors
course pour ses trente minutes puisque
la direction de course avait rajouté
deux heures normand vous êtes obligé de
sortir de votre épreuve quelles que
soient les conditions au bout de 24
heures là il avait repoussé de deux
heures les gars la difficulté de
l'épreuve pour autant en a pointé 26
heures 30 donc trente minutes de trop
donc on a abandonné entre guillemets non
vois pas ce que la voiture ne
fonctionnait plus mais parce qu'on était
hors course
on va parler de vos objectifs sur ce
dakar
vous allez peut-être remporter la course
pour la ram et dans les yvelines
c'est être compliqué alors très
honnêtement la course du courage
peut-être la course de l'ingéniosité
pour arriver au bout peut-être en vain
je doute qu'on vienne ennuyé
ni sébastien loeb ni peterhansel d'abord
parce qu'on n'a pas les mêmes outils
pour travailler une fois de plus six ans
c'est une équipe d'usiné dont vous avez
une dizaine de mécano dans le team qui
va rire reconditionnés l'auto en
permanence et puis sont des gens qui
sont hyper entraînés
c'est ça votre dernier dakar vous
comptez continuer encore non je pense
que quelque part nombreux pilotes le
disent c'est vrai que quand on commence
à goûter à ce type d' aventure
l'intensité alors c'est sûr que si vous
me posez la question au milieu d'une
dune au bout du cinquième jour pendant
que je suis en train de pelleter
probablement que je vous dirais que
c'est le dernier
pour autant on sait qu'avec le temps qui
passe l envie de repartir est toujours
là parce que l'intensité des moments que
vous vivez dans ses aventures là elle
dépasse le cadre du quotidien personnes
ont rarement en tout cas dans son
quotidien on a des situations aussi
extrême des situations aussi difficiles
vont finalement là le bonheur de tout ça
c'est probablement ce que recherche la
majeure partie des sportifs c'est
d'aller au delà de ce qu'on imaginait
possible est typiquement c'est ce
challenge qui est fabuleux et c'est
quand on revient évidemment c'est
bizarre de se reconnecter au monde en
général vous mettez à peu près trois
semaines un mois avant de retoucher
terre
vous êtes rentré en europe vous vous
dites ce que j'ai vécu est dingue
et puis petit à petit le travail se fait
dans la tête et vous n'avez qu'une envie
c'est de repartir donc dire que ce sera
mon dernier dakar probablement pas non
non c'est une trop belle aventure pour
l'arrêter tant que je pourrai participer
à ce type d'épreuve je le ferais quoi
c'est noté tristan merci beaucoup en
tout cas nous avons accueilli dans votre
garage ici à mézy-sur-seine biais d'une
interview
merci à vous et je rappelle aux
téléspectateurs le dakar ça commence le
2 janvier c'est la fin de ce sept huit
invités bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]